اعلنت كتائب القسام ايقاع اربع عربات
عسكريه اسرائيليه في كمين محكم في منطقه
جحر الديك وسط قطاع غزه وقالت الكتائب
انها فجرت حقلا من العبوات المضاده
للافراد والدروع بالقوه الاسرائيليه ما
ادى الى مقتل جميع افرادها وسحقهم وفق ما
وصفه او وصفته كتائب القسام واضافت
الكتائب ان مقاتليها دمروا دبابه صهيون
هرعت الى المكان بقذيفه الياسين 105
واستهدفوا قوات النجده والاخلاء بمنطقه
العمليه بمنظومه الصواريخ رجوم وقذائف
الهاون من العيار الثقيل وكانت الكتائب قد
اعلنت في وقت سابق ان مقاتليها يخوضون
اشتباكات مسلحه منذ امس مع قوات الاحتلال
المتوغلة
العمل الفدائي وقذائف الياسين 105 المضاده
للدروع وقذائف تي بي جي المضاده للافراد
والتحصينات وقالت كتائب القسام انها اوقعت
عددا كبيرا من الجنود الاسرائيليين بين
قتيل وجريح في منطقه جبالي البلد وان
الاشتباكات لا تزال مستمره واضافت كتائب
القسام انها اجهزت على اربعه جنود
اسرائيليين من مسافه صفر في حي القصاصيب
بمخيم جباليا واكدت القسام تدمير خمس
دبابات في جباليا وقتل واصابه من فيها
باستخدام صاروخين يزن كل منهما طن اطلقه
ما جيش الاحتلال ولم ينفجرا كما اعلنت
تفجير مدخل نفق في قوه اسرائيليه خاصه في
جحر الديك وسط قطاع غزه وايقاع افرادها
بين قتيل وجريح واكدت القسام انها قصفت
بقذائف الهاون من العيار الثقيل غرف
القياده الميدانيه لقوات احتلال في المحور
الجنوبي لمدينه
غزه